good morning thank you for being here  when I look ahead at we're computing is  headed it's clear to me that we are  heading evolving from a mobile first to  an AI first world people will be able to  interact with it naturally and  seamlessly than ever before and above  all else it will be intelligent at  Google we are very very excited about  the shift and we've been working for a  long time towards issue at the heart of  these efforts these are goal to build a  Googler system we spoke about the  assistant earlier at Google i/o this  year the invasion the assistant as a  two-way conversation a natural dialogue  between our users in Google the  assistant will be universal it will be  available when the users need it to help  them and our goal is to build a personal  google for each and every user